[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Ну, це не машина, так?
[Закарпаття, полонина Пересліп
Літній табір буйволів]
З буйволами треба жити разом,
мати покликання до тварин і мати час.
Коли я був студентом-екологом,
трохи шукав інформацію про них.
Я знайшов, що є ще буйволи у Греції,  Болгарії,
Македонії, Сербії, Україні,
Румунії та на Балканах.
Потім я шукав буйволів в Карпатах.
[Мішель Якобі
Приїхав з Німеччини рятувати карпатських буйволів]
У 2008 році я повернувся сюди,
до Карпат, шукати буйволів.
[кличе буйволиць] Бура! Коше! Регіна!
Крістіна! Зараз йдемо в долину.
Селяни з долин казали,
що поки тут не з'явились комуністи, більшовики,
буйволів було більше, ніж корів.
У кожному селі було 300, 400, 500 буйволів.
У Кричово, Велятино —
там було дуже багато буйволів.
Люди, яких називали ґаздами або куркулями,
мали по 5-6 буйволів.
Комуністи забирали тварин,
а хто не хотів віддавати — їхав до Сибіру.
Але буйволи чужим людям не дають молока.
Отак забирали з родини буйвола, і потім
просто так тримали [не знали, що з ним робити].
Коли більшовики, комуністи забирали,
то більшість буйволів одразу помирала.
Карпатський буйвол має спортивну фігуру,
він дуже розумний.
Роги такі, як у вола: рівні, гострі.
Дуже цікаво, що коли він росте
разом з людьми поблизу хижі,
він має характер, як у домашнього пса,
дуже розумний, любить свого господаря.
На ньому можна кататися верхи, як на коні.
Колись давно люди жили
поруч із тваринами, разом.
Як тепер ще старі люди живуть:
просто біля своєї кімнати, біля дому мають хлів.
І вранці перша робота —
давати воду і сіно тваринам.
Тоді відчуваєш, як тварина встає, як вона живе.
Коли тварина реве, то знаєш, що вона хоче,
бо ти завжди близько біля своєї скотини.
Так живе вже мало людей.
У старших людей це ще можна спостерігати.
Старші люди кажуть,
що молодь вже не хоче так тримати тварин.
Буйволів треба тримати змалечку близько до рук.
Кожного дня говорити з ними.
Випускати, прив’язувати на вулиці, відпускати
на поле. Він підходить до хліба, до знайомих рук.
Треба жити разом, щоб була
така культура життя в гармонії з природою.
Щаслива? Ти пив? Супер.
Мама дає молоко? Все добре?
Не можна казати: «Ой, буйволи б’ються,
я не дою, віддаю їх на м'ясо і все».
Буйволи потрібні. Восени — щоб сіно возити додому. Взимку — щоб тягти дрова. Влітку — орати поля.
І цілий рік дає молоко.
Якщо народився бичок —
буде добре м'ясо.
Є один великий заповідник, коло Дунаю.
Там є острів, куди
можна пустити декількох буйволів.
Там уже є дикі коні.
Разом з ними дикі буйволи можуть там
цілий рік пастися без людей.
Там зими не такі тяжкі.
Це розумна перспектива для таких буйволів, як Рая.
Вона після шести років ще
не дає молока і не йде до рук.
Дружба є, просто вона не вірить мені,
не дає молока.
Вона б’є або лягає.
Але вона дуже розумна,
справжня карпатська буйволиця.
Люди питають:
«Ну скільки буйвол може дати молока?»
Я кажу: «Ну просто молока п'ять літрів».
Вони відповідають: «А, це мало».
Але як мало?
Якщо йдеться про жирність,
то тут є 10 відсотків жиру.
Корова дає 10-15 літрів молока,
яке має 2-3 відсотки жиру.
Я теж можу додавати десять літрів води до молока
і казати, що буйвол дає 10-15 літрів молока.
Просто там води багато.
А у буйвола дуже жирне молоко.
Люди кажуть: в кисле молоко ложка стає.
І сметана такий класний продукт, хто знає,
це цінний продукт.
Тут внизу найбільші букові праліси у світі.
І тут, під Близницею, така полонина —
дуже-дуже велика.
Люди кажуть — нічия,
але там ще коней дуже багато.
Таких гарних територій я ще ніколи не бачив.
Таке буйволи люблять їсти.
Особливо коли щось солодке.
Ну, коли в пакеті був хліб чи тушонка,
чи хто знає яке сміття.
Якщо багато буйвол їсть сміття,
то не довго житиме.
Це видно у Крістіни —
вона найбільше любить їсти сміття.
І Бура, яка сьогодні дала молока, теж любить.
Вона їсть-їсть-їсть, але вже не поправиться.
Там повний шлунок сміття. Пробка там.
Одного разу ми різали одного бика,
який мав півтора року.
У його шлунку було два кілограми сміття.
Мотузки, целофан, пінопласт, все таке тонке.
Пластмаса.
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Монтаж
Микола Носок]
[Музика
Даха Браха, Fudo Kazuki]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]